welcome to this video playing gb ray oh
gee brain played it before but I don't
remember the result they are playing the
Russell limo here it is playing this d6
hybrid system Duchess some um online
that I have played myself actually so
good to mix of being solid but still
offering some ways to complicate Bishop
d7 can easily get a bit a bit a bit down
on move 3 ok this was sorry this was
this move on but it's also about this
check and then 96 leading to the same
position is quite good ok so here's some
spending some time here curiously enough
nope it's not a connection issue no my
collection at least is fine we just he
just took Oh up okay I don't know look
you won or c 3 is probably the way to go
ya know is playing quickly maybe he had
some something irritating him like a
doorbell or something it happens all the
time while you playing mmm so II 697 is
his son it's a setup okay maybe I can
try to make it a bit more difficult for
him to play be 5v5 I can take take AHAT
six winning upon so is preventing that
and now be sure before I was my idea
but they can make a play this year yeah
he can play that with no problems at all
and then f5 hmm
yeah I don't really have any great
knowledge about this line and it shows
I'm already oh this I don't mind so much
at 5 f-5 was was more often on an issue
for me this alike now actually g3 Bishop
g2 I've got two bishops in a semi-open
position it's not not too bad he moves
the night away it doesn't I wonder
wonder I wonder Bishop Bishop g5 many
provoking f6 yeah but if six is it such
an accomplishment hmm this pawn here on
c5 would be nice to to attack
maybe cavity three and yeah he was he
was maybe worried about that hands and
when i bought some i want to get this
pawn hmm i can always play Bishop f8 if
he wants
it's simply not a good plan maybe now
maybe this one if he goes to e 79 IG
form hmm this one
hmm all right
yeah this was so it was really bad play
by me me oh no it's giving me age six
check don't really know why
yeah maybe my erratic player somewhere
irritated him just like it irritated me
yeah just take it and run so to say and
I can go back and back to see for maybe
h4 h5 making something out of it yeah
this is an fact a good idea so just just
hear him yeah it did before just weekend
till we get his position he wants to do
something active but understandably but
it mostly mostly weekend wicked black
sir blacks position okay yeah I once
play Knight to e5 okay this is the
easiest I just need to protect against
95 then Bishop e3 or something Bishop f4
it doesn't have fun any realistic ways
to to make any progress here hmm ok just
the ticket you for me don't see how he
defends it
yeah I think it's just gone III maybe
like III Queen takes takes on f2 last
chance at some some checks of this
and I don't see a move i think i can
just take you for next and then it fell
apart it falls apart yeah the sort of
last last resort check ok i take it yeah
i can really take it check so it's
really just just a couple of checks
check
hmm is it
Wow
who what
night
time warning check
it's the only only thing are so against
this it's enough but what a shocker
check check check check check black for
fits on time close to stalemate really
close systemic wow what a shocker with
94 I really thought okay this this is
over I mean it probably was but a check
check it's jen looked like a shocking
move check yeah it was I think the only
only way to play I didn't I didn't see
another move he's threatening nighty too
maybe 92 King King h one night after yep
okay but it's cd4 is a win yeah I played
I played this really badly because I
didn't really hear it didn't really I
think this is this is quite okay for
white I should be in decent shape here
with the two bishops the good night here
it's not clever bh4 or something but I
played some pretty aimless moves and
there was lucky that is somehow
blundered th614 for nothing and they're
here white is in excellent shape of
course just enjoying the porn and the
better structure I'm just a bit bit
uncoordinated with them it's this is
something that can be fixed and this was
enough but this really
send some shivers down my spine thanks
for watching